[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco
aquí en francia porque la salida de la
pandemia tiene un marcado carácter
electoral en francia con las elecciones
de 2022 pues ya la vuelta de la esquina
y con la mayoría de partidos decidiendo
sus candidatos conmigo en este estudio
marx va a ser corresponsal del país en
francia bienvenido marc hola muchas
gracias florencia ángeles corresponsal
de la radio w en colombia bienvenida de
hacer estar aquí
rafael cruise compañero periodista del
político del diario la opinión
bienvenido gracias buenas a todos
francia en la antesala de la carrera
electoral hoy en primera plana
como les decíamos la salida de la
pandemia tiene un marcado carácter
electoral en francia con las elecciones
de 2022 ya la vista la mayoría de
formaciones políticas decidiendo quién
competirá contra el presidente macrón
según los sondeos además partiría de
favorito frente a la ultraderechista le
penó o los candidatos que ya vamos
conociendo como la socialista anne
hidalgo o el ecologista ya han hinchado
una izquierda desunida una derecha con
luchas intestinas y además un elemento
perturbador el periodista
ultraderechista eric samur que está
protagonizando este momento político en
el país prometiendo ser el revulsivo de
la próxima cita electoral repasemos
algunas portadas antes de analizar todo
esto libération se puede debatir con
quien sea políticos y medios de
comunicación se interrogan sobre cómo
tratar la figura de eric se muere este
elemento nuevo perturbador de este
inicio de curso político le figaro macro
ni la derecha frente a la escalada del
fémur dice el diario conservador que los
candidatos están obligados a revisar sus
estrategias con un fémur fuerte en los
sondeos revista logs dedica su portada a
la figura hallado que acaba de ganar las
primarias del partido ecologista ante
una / el diario le parisien se
preguntaba también esta semana para
cuando una mujer en el elíseo en el
recuerdo colectivo el intento de la
socialista ségolène guay al en el 2007
cuando perdió frente a nicolas sarkozy
pero vamos a repasar las figuras
políticas pero antes les quería hacer la
misma pregunta de los tres factores que
claves a modo de titulares van a definir
esta carrera electoral por ellis o en
2022 marc bueno quedan seis meses
todavía pueden pasar muchas cosas en
francia en el mundo no hace falta
recordar la pandemia hace dos años es
decir no sabemos de qué estaremos
debatiendo en abril que es cuando se las
elecciones pero yo diría que hay por lo
menos dos temas que pueden estructurar
la campaña y dependiendo de cuál sea
preminente tendrá más peso los otros
candidatos uno es la identidad que
englobaría pues de inmigración soberanía
todas estas cuestiones que en francia
gusta mucho debatir y preocupan a una
parte de la población otra y creo que
puede ser la economía después de la
pandemia de los confinamientos francia
sale con cifras económicas buenas
reforzadas pero no deja de ser un tema
siempre importante en el bolsillo de los
votantes y luego hay un tercer tema
que debería ser muy importante pero en
este momento no tengo claro que lo sea
que es la ecología y el medio ambiente
florencia si yo también creo que es
importantísimo la cuestión económica no
también cómo salir de esta crisis
sanitaria ya tenemos unas cifras en
francia pero también si eso se traduce o
no en el poder adquisitivo de la gente
también ya tenemos algunos anuncios
demanda macro con respecto al
congelamiento de tarifas que eso parece
que también eso ahorita que estamos con
este este problema a nivel mundial en
cuanto a electricidad tarifas
energéticas son también esta cuestión
monetaria no poder adquisitivos la gente
va a pesar la inmigración sin duda ya
lleva varios meses también siendo un
tema nacional y bueno la ecología yo
creo que también hay que ver como luego
lo sacan todos los candidatos para que
no sea un lastre y que al contrario haya
propuestas muy importantes y que la
gente puede estar entonces identificada
en esta en ese tema rafael si estoy de
acuerdo en la cuestión social el poder
adquisitivo es algo que hay que vigilar
porque claro no es el tema que ahora
mismo
dominando el debate pero vemos con el
aumento de los precios de la
electricidad y del gas
sabiendo que en este país hubo un
movimiento social llamado los chalecos
amarillos
ojo porque esto puede explotarlo pero se
puede en cualquier momento podemos pasar
de una situación en la que se debate
mucho de la identidad de la inmigración
poco menos de la ecología pero la
cohesión social en francia siempre puede
[Música]
pues pasará en primera página en muy
poco tiempo
el presidente macro lidera los sondeos
pese a todos los problemas como decíamos
que arrastra durante el quinquenio sobre
todo los pre más sociales con los
chalecos amarillos con las protestas
pero llega al final de la pandemia muy
bien en los sondeos y con unos muy
buenos datos económicos con la mayoría
de los indicadores en verde creen que
llega en el mejor momento para macrón
justo ahora al final del quinquenio para
encarar esta guerra electoral marc yo
creo que es que sí que el término es
bueno para el presidente y yo creo que
efectivamente seguramente es el mejor
momento para macrón ha pasado a la
pandemia ha cometido como casi todos los
gobiernos democráticos errores graves
pero
en estos momentos la inmensa mayoría de
franceses están vacunados las medidas
económicas que de urgencia que adoptó el
gobierno macrón durante la los
confinamientos y la pandemia se han
resultado que han funcionado y que la
economía el paro el desempleo baja la
economía crece y luego esta cosa muy
coyuntural pero que son los sondeos
durante yo no recuerdo haber visto
sondeos tan buenos para macro me tengan
a las elecciones desde desde que salió
elegido en el 2017 ahora esto con la
cautela y repito mi respuesta edad nos
falta falta de medio año todavía para
las elecciones y puede haber muchísimos
giros es decir lo que en la foto de
ahora y es improbable que sea la foto de
marzo abril 2022 y también conviene
todavía no decirlo formalmente porque
todos sabemos creo que se va a presentar
también entonces el hecho de que no lo
haga todavía de manera formal también le
da este margen triste pero bueno
pero se anunció que a lo mejor no sé si
va a ganar el lectores pero al menos va
estar que haya movimientos sociales como
el que hicimos de los chalecos amarillos
esta cuestión el plan marsella que estos
días que anunció hace unas semanas en
marsella en para un sector poblacional
también muy desfavorable de favorecido
perdón también la cuestión de lo
decíamos los cheques energéticos y
también estas medidas que vayas hacen
con el presupuesto finalmente que tiene
pero le dan una ventaja sumando lo que
dicen los sondeos los liberales
ultraderecha conservadores en todas las
encuestas de opinión podemos decir que
en general este país ha basculado mucho
a la derecha rafael
bueno desde el punto de vista electoral
yo diría que la batalla cultural acerca
de los temas como decía a marc de
identidad de inmigración de integración
del tema de los mensajeros en general
esa batalla cultural si ha sido ganada
por la derecha en la ultraderecha hace
ya muchos años la verdad no ha sabido
responder prueba de ello es que parte de
la izquierda no toda la izquierda pero
parte de la izquierda está en una
está cazando en terrenos ajenos de lo
que es la ideología tradicional de la
izquierda
si vemos por ejemplo un candidato que no
tiene mucha oportunidad de ganar la
elección que estábamos montbui pues dice
claramente en la radio que en las
cuestiones económicas es sociales hay
que ser de izquierda pero que lo que
toca en policía seguridad inmigración
hay que ser derechas porque es lo que
quieren los franceses entonces dentro de
la izquierda está yo no diría una
escisión pero hay dos maneras de ver ese
tema y verdad que parte de la izquierda
pues valida los temas o al final los uno
que dice la derecha entiende que en
temas como la seguridad hay que comprar
ciertos preceptos que ha vendido a la
derecha tradicionalmente hay que ser
fuerte que hay que dejar de ser
angélicos es la palabra que a los
políticos franceses les gusta mucho no
el angelismo de hay que pensar estos
temas con responsabilidad y claro pero
esto tiene como consecuencia el
debilitar el discurso tradicional de la
izquierda sobre esas cuestiones de la
tolerancia o el fue el foco con la
prevención por ejemplo este país
electrizado en los últimos años
no sabría yo creo que este país es de
derechas desde hace más tiempo
pero creo que es una frase que dijo
mitterrand que limitarán está robando de
hace 30 o 40 años que este es un país de
derechas que de vez en cuando por
también voto vota a la izquierda pero es
una derecha muy particular no quizá por
el origen por la tradición bonapartista
por la tradición del antiguo régimen de
la monarquía absoluta una derecha vista
estatista y no liberal es decir cuando
hablamos de que sea de lisette
derechizado el país se han hechizado en
cuestiones como como decía rafael de de
seguridad inmigración de cierre de
fronteras pero los franceses tienen a su
estado pero quieren un estado fuerte y
la derecha francesa no es una derecha
como podríamos decir como fue la de
ronald reagan en los años 80 o margaret
thatcher o otras derechas en otros
lugares sino que es una derecha que
quiere un estado fuerte que gaste y que
intervenga en la economía el liberalismo
yo creo en todos los aspectos tanto
económico como social en francia no es
el viaje de número gracias quiere
sentirse protegido
de qué derecho estamos hablando porque
en este país hay varias derechas y con
lo desde molo estamos viendo de manera
clara de qué derecho estamos hablando la
que gobierna con mayor la que está en la
oposición o la que está con mariló penn
y la autodenominada derecha nacional y
existen por lo menos tres corrientes de
derechas ahora mismo en francia bueno
pues como decía rafael a todo esto
irrumpe una figura en la escena política
francesa que todo lo tambalea y que ni
siquiera los medios sabemos muy bien
cómo tratar expliquemos lo primero a
nuestros oyentes y televidentes quienes
él dice moore quien cree explicar lo que
básicamente dan unas pinceladas básicas
porque es el fenómeno del que todo el
mundo habla ahora mismo en francia pues
adelante el demo es un ensayista
periodista
autor de varios libros con bastante
mundo temático de que digamos que es un
personaje que lleva ya muchos años en
los medios como periodista tenía una
crónica en el periódico el diario lo
hago también intervinó muchos años en un
programa de televisión el sábado por la
noche en la televisión pública entonces
es una cara conocida por los oyentes los
los agentes de los periódicos y ve la
tele
decía monotemático porque es una figura
que lleva a cabo un discurso sobre la
identidad
digamos la caída de los valores
franceses
hay que subrayar que fue condenado por
la justicia por incitar al odio racial
entonces
mucha gente en este país lo considera un
racista y una
es el principal
emisor de ideas racistas en este en este
país y ahora parece que está a punto de
lanzarse una carrera electoral todavía
se da por descontado también y aparece
muerto profesional y aparece muy fuerte
en los sondeos aquí lo atribuyes este
fenómeno de moore florencia marc porque
existe este fenómeno si como como
calibrarlo si bueno como dice rafael
también es una figura muy polémica y que
hablábamos hace unos instantes que uno
de los temas también que donde va a
girar esta campaña es en cuestión de
inmigración y él ha sido muy muy crítico
hacia la inmigración y también hacia el
islam recordemos viene también de
orígenes judíos ha siempre tenido esta
visión de bueno está la inmigración que
viene de países árabes cada vez ganando
más fuerza en europa y en francia
particularmente y allí se está agarrando
poco el tema de marín de pena marido
penn al contrario ella ha
recurrido a ésta desde abolición del
frente nacional y entonces ha dejado
este hueco para que la gente que estaba
muy
muy allegada o muy convencida por el
frente nacional que ahora se llama
hanson nuevo nación al encuentro
nacional se vaya a sentimos yo creo que
por ahí ha empezado también a ganar más
adeptos y es sorprendente porque a
inicios de septiembre los sondeos le
daban 7 por ciento y ahora en octubre ya
llegó hasta un 11 por ciento no me vais
a permitir que alguna breve pausa y
enseguida seguimos analizando el
fenómeno eric zemmour y lo seguimos
calibrando aquí en primera plana hasta
ahora
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actually team
hola bienvenidos a revista digital una
inmersión en profundidad en lo bueno lo
malo y lo feo del mundo digital un
reportaje de la televisión francesa
dedicado a denunciar los post a escenas
clandestinas en parís desde la
democratización de la información a
través de las redes sociales hasta la
masificación de las técnicas obtener una
línea telefónica en méxico ahora
requerirá que usted proporcione hasta
sus datos biométricos
[Música]
acompáñeme la crónica de revista digital
por france 24 y france 24 puntocom
ah
[Música]
eeuu y el grupo talibán entabla en los
primeros diálogos desde la toma de kabul
en agosto pasado instalados en qatar
discuten la evacuación de los
extranjeros que quedan en suelo afgano
la ayuda humanitaria y una eventual
cooperación para combatir al estado
islámico las dos centrales eléctricas
más grandes del líbano están cerradas
por la escasez de combustible la
consecuencia ha sido varios apagones que
continuarán al menos hasta el lunes la
compañía estatal de electricidad intenta
utilizar la reserva de gasolina del
ejército venezuela terminó de retirar
los contenedores que bloqueaban el paso
hacia colombia por el puente
internacional francisco de paula
santander es la nueva medida para
reabrir las fronteras entre los dos
países aunque el cruce todavía es
limitado
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 yo soy maría de
la calle
hablemos de eeuu y el grupo talibán
porque hoy se reunieron por primera vez
desde que las tropas extranjeras se
retiraron de afganistán los diálogos se
realizan este fin de semana en la
capital qatarí doha la casa blanca
quiere discutir la evacuación de los
estadounidenses que quedan en este país
del medio oriente y de quienes
colaboraron con ellos por su parte el
grupo talibán busca que la ayuda
humanitaria llegue a todo el territorio
y por ahora descarta cooperar con eeuu
para luchar conjuntamente contra el
autodenominado estado islámico
poco más de un mes desde que el último
soldado estadounidense abandonar
afganistán eeuu está celebrando su
primera reunión en persona con los
nuevos gobernantes del país los
talibanes las delegaciones llegaron a
doha en qatar este fin de semana el
departamento de estado de eeuu hizo
hincapié en que la reunión no supone el
reconocimiento del gobierno talibán
tenemos claro que cualquier legitimidad
debe ganarse a través de las acciones de
los talibanes
washington quiere garantías de que los
talibanes cumplirán su compromiso de
permitir que los ciudadanos
estadounidenses abandonen el país
decenas de ellos todavía están tratando
de salir junto con miles de afganos
elegibles para visas estadounidenses la
delegación norteamericana también quiere
que los talibanes permitan entrar a
ayuda humanitaria mientras el país
enfrenta una severa crisis económica la
reunión de dos días se produce poco
después de un atentado suicida con bomba
en la ciudad de kunduz al norte de
afganistán que mató a decenas de fieles
de una mezquita chií cientos de personas
acudieron a los funerales a despedir a
sus familiares y exigieron protección a
la autoridad talibán
este ataque arroja dudas sobre la
promesa de los talibanes de devolver la
seguridad al país después de décadas de
violencia
les aseguramos a nuestros hermanos
chiítas que en el futuro les brindaremos
seguridad y que esos problemas no les
volverán a ocurrir
a toda la nación incluido en nosotros y
nuestros ancianos está de luto con ellos
verdad el ataque del viernes es solo el
último realizado por la rama local del
grupo estado islámico los rivales de los
talibanes han intensificado una campaña
de ataques mortales desde la retirada de
eeuu en un intento por desestabilizar a
los nuevos gobernantes de afganistán
las dos centrales eléctricas más grandes
de líbano cerraron por la escasez de
combustible esto generó apagones en
varias áreas incluyendo las afueras de
beirut y afectó principalmente a la
población más empobrecida que no tiene
acceso a suministros privados de energía
desde beirut el periodista joan cabasés
nos envió el siguiente reporte
hacía semanas que era una posibilidad y
finalmente hoy se ha confirmado la red
eléctrica nacional de líbano ha quedado
paralizada el estado es incapaz de
ofrecer un solo minuto de energía al día
la falta de combustible que golpea el
líbano ha bloqueado las plantas
eléctricas del país en realidad es esa
misma escasez la que hace que durante
meses el estado haya sido incapaz de
ofrecer más de una o de dos horas de luz
al día ahora el apagón actual afectará
especialmente a la población que reside
en la parte montañosa del líbano y que
dependía de la red pública para mantener
sus casas calientes la ausencia del
estado hace que casas comercios y
hospitales dependan del mercado los
generadores privados continúan
funcionando pero lo hacen a un precio
que muy pocos bolsillos se pueden
permitir obtener 13 horas de energía
diarias puede costar al menos 200
dólares mensuales lo que es una cifra
muy superior al valor actual del sueldo
mínimo libanés el actual apagón podría
alargarse días o incluso días pero en
líbano todo el mundo asume que la falta
de combustible
a provocar episodios similares durante
el próximo invierno en irak prima el
ausentismo entre jóvenes votantes para
las elecciones legislativas anticipadas
que se celebrarán este fin de semana
hacia los esfuerzos de las autoridades
por incentivar el voto los electores
manifiestan su decepción con la clase
política dirigente y las crisis
económicas y sociales que asolan al país
millones de personas ya habían
protestado en 2019 ante estas
problemáticas marinas sardiña tiene más
información
votar conduce a la realización de tus
demandas repetían a través de unos
altavoces las fuerzas de seguridad
iraquíes en un intento para incentivar
el voto en los comicios legislativos que
se celebrarán este domingo en irak y que
están marcados por el descontento social
y la desconfianza política
yo no votaré porque los resultados no
serán creíbles no creo que estas
elecciones sean libres y honestas y no
creo que un iraquí honorable pueda ser
candidato entre otros grupos porque
todos son unos fracasados y no aman a su
país ni son leales sino que quieren
regalarlo
a la corrupción y la mala gestión de los
partidos tradicionales han hecho que
miles de iraquíes se nieguen a acudir a
las urnas mientras los expertos
pronostican que la clase política
mantendrá su control del poder y
los resultados de las elecciones
iraquíes se conocen y es un juego en el
que las clases políticas se turnan y se
reparten los ministerios entre ellos así
como el primer ministerio la presidencia
del parlamento y la presidencia está
claro cada cuatro años rotan
las elecciones se celebran un año antes
de lo previsto debido a las masivas
protestas antigubernamentales que
sacudieron el país en 2019 cuando
millones de jóvenes salieron a las
calles para exigir mejoras democráticas
y una salida al desempleo y el
desmoronamiento de los servicios
públicos dos años después la situación
sigue siendo precaria
los jóvenes son los más perjudicados en
este país especialmente por el gobierno
a nosotros nos mataron durante las
protestas y los recién licenciados están
en paro
más de 3400 candidatos compiten por 329
escaños en el parlamento en lo que son
los quintos comicios desde la invasión
estadounidense de irak en 2003 y en las
elecciones parlamentarias de república
checa hay una sorpresa con el 99 5% de
los votos contados la oposición de
centroderecha de la coalición juntos
venció al partido del primer ministro
and day' davis a pesar de que los
oficialistas llevaban la ventaja juntos
y los liberales también de oposición
ganaron 108 escaños así pueden unir sus
fuerzas para hacer la mayoría de los
cientos parlamentarios
en españa el aeropuerto de la palma
reabrió después de haber cerrado dos
días por las cenizas que ha emitido el
volcán cumbre vieja las erupciones
continúan y ahora las coladas van en
múltiples direcciones porque la cara
norte del cono de la erupción se
derrumbó el magma gana cada vez más
terreno en el mar y si sigue avanzando
podría derrumbarse alva santana tiene
los detalles los ríos de lava se han
convertido en una imagen cotidiana en la
palma desde el 19 de septiembre el
volcán de compra vieja no ha cesado su
actividad pero el sábado con la ruptura
de su cara norte las coladas
incrementaron llevándose por delante
varias casas de la localidad de todo que
pueden casa encerrado pero el terrenito
que tenía en todos
la montaña de alimentos
los recuerdos de mis padres
pero diría que ya césar a todo esto ya
de una vez por todas que no seguir
haciendo daño porque es que cada vez
está haciendo más años pasando por zona
que se pensaba que no iba a pasar y está
pasando a pesar de los numerosos
movimientos sísmicos a raíz de la
actividad volcánica este sábado las
autoridades locales decidieron reabrir
el aeropuerto de la isla y aseguraron
que las coladas actuales no representan
un peligro en este momento con las
cantidades de lava y la posición y
movimiento de la colada no estamos en
necesidad de hacer todo eso puesto que
ya tenemos todo lo que está por debajo
evacuado entonces también pido en ese
aspecto tranquilidad y estar siempre
atento a las indicaciones que hagan las
autoridades de protección civil desde
que el volcán entró en erupción su lava
ha engullido al menos 480 hectáreas de
tierra en la palma
más de 1100 edificios junto a la
evacuación de cerca de 6.000 personas y
noticias de francia el presidente de
manuel marco dijo que su país lanzará
una campaña para la abolición mundial de
la pena de muerte esto lo hará cuando
ejerza la presidencia rotatoria de la
unión europea durante el primer semestre
de 2022 bajo hizo la afirmación en la
conmemoración del aniversario 40 de la
abolición del castigo en francia aseguró
que trabajará con otros estados miembros
para lograr una resolución de las
naciones unidas que requiera que los
países informen cada año el número de
condenas a muerte dictadas y de
ejecuciones hablo junto a bbva than tag
el ministro de justicia del fallecido
presidente françois mitterrand quien
lideró la iniciativa en 1982
[Música]
hoy 9 de octubre de 2021 anunció que
francia relanzará su lucha por la
abolición universal de la pena de muerte
esto se llevará a cabo en el marco de la
presidencia de la unión europea
organizaremos una reunión de alto nivel
en parís en cooperación con una ong que
lucha contra la pena de muerte este
encuentro reunirá a organizaciones de la
sociedad civil de países que aún tienen
la pena de muerte y busca convencer a
sus líderes de la importancia y urgencia
de la abolición cuando con gran color
difusión donde concedió jones del
embrión cambiemos de continente y vamos
a américa venezuela ya terminó de
remover los contenedores del puente
internacional francisco de paula
santander que durante dos años
bloquearon el paso hacia colombia esto
permitió el paso peatonal por la segunda
vía más importante que comunica a los
dos países el pasado lunes el desbloqueo
fue en el puente simón bolívar sin
embargo el paso todavía es limitado y
sólo se permite el cruce del personal
médico y estudiantil estamos esperando
por las autoridades de colombia ya no
existe ningún obstáculo en la república
bolivariana de venezuela
y valga la redundancia evite o limite la
apertura comercial
progresiva y de oscuridad y el commit 19
ya deja más de 15 millones de personas
muertas en américa latina según el
conteo de la agencia afp que recolecta
datos oficiales la región es la más
golpeada por la pandemia brasil encabeza
la lista de los países latinoamericanos
con más de 600 mil decesos a causa del
virus que siguen méxico perú colombia y
argentina
y en rusia la crisis del hobbit 19 sigue
en aumento mientras la pandemia parece
remitir en muchas zonas del mundo como
en europa e incluso en américa latina'
este país registró su récord de decesos
diarios este sábado al llegar a los 968
algunas de las causas son la baja tasa
de vacunación las dudas que existen
respecto a la inoculación sputnik ve a
la inexistencia de otras alternativas
veamos el informe de álvaro cordero
rusia atraviesa su peor fase de la
pandemia desde hace semanas tienen la
tasa de mortalidad más alta del planeta
a pesar de haber iniciado la vacunación
en diciembre tras 11 meses apenas un
tercio de su población tiene al menos
una dosis datos preocupantes en
comparación con los de los países de
europa o de américa latina que van
progresando hacia la inmunidad rebaño la
desconfianza de los rusos hacia la
vacuna es la principal de las causas
desde moscú solamente se ha autorizado
la inmunización con sputnik p y se ha
evitado aprobar las dosis procedentes
del extranjero algo llamativo ya que
sputnik ve a pesar de ser una de las
primeras en salir al mercado sigue sin
contar con el visto bueno de la o ms el
kremlin ya ha reconocido de forma
oficial el fracaso en la vacunación y ha
redoblado esfuerzos para incentivar que
la gente se inmunice
ante anna pons sin su estructura la tasa
de vacunación a pesar de la completa
preparación de toda la infraestructura
deja mucho que desear en producción
estable
una vez más hacemos un llamado a todos
para que se vacunen porque esta es la
única forma de proteger sus vidas frente
a una pandemia
sin una tasa de vacunación completa que
ronda el 80 por ciento resulta
complicado frenar una ola de contagios
que va en aumento por los efectos de la
variante delta y la llegada del invierno
y papá francisco le pidió a todos los
legisladores del mundo que superen los
límites de la política partidista para
poder alcanzar un consenso sobre la
lucha contra el cambio climático el sumo
pontífice le habló a los parlamentarios
que se reunieron en roma de cara a la
cumbre cop 26 de la onu en glasgow que
comenzará el 31 de octubre
de nuestra casa común herri entre el
cuidado de nuestra casa común cae
naturalmente dentro del alcance de estos
principios ciertamente no se trata sólo
de desalentar y sancionar las prácticas
indebidas más que sobre las frutos de
incentivar sino también y sobre todo de
fomentar concretamente nuevos caminos a
seguir
racing
son especies en caminos más adecuados a
los objetivos que buscamos alcanzar
para cerrar música clásica la décima
sinfonía de beethoven fue completada con
inteligencia artificial esta es la única
sinfonía que el compositor alemán no
alcanzó a terminar antes de morir en
1827 ahora para conmemorar su
aniversario de nacimiento
250 un equipo de musicólogos y
programadores desarrolló un algoritmo
que jugó con los fragmentos que ya
existían y luego improviso este fue el
resultado
sigan con más en france 24
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
analizando cómo se presenta la antesala
de la carrera electoral en francia con
la mayoría de formaciones políticas pues
envueltos en procesos de primarias o con
candidatos que ya se van decidiendo no
lo ha hecho todavía el presidente manuel
macro aunque se da por descontado no lo
ha hecho todavía pues este fenómeno que
ha irrumpido en esta antesala que del
que estábamos hablando antes de la pausa
eric se moore y lo hacemos con florencia
ángeles corresponsal de w en parís
rafael plus del diario la opinión y marc
va a ser corresponsal del diario 'el
país' en francia marca hablamos antes de
damos esos perfiles a pinceladas de
quiénes eric zemmour que pretender ixe
moore y sobre todo a quien puede hacerle
daño
no sabemos bien qué pretende
qué pretende es la cuestión no pero no
tenemos claro tampoco por lo menos
pretende vender libros
hay que decir que ya lo hacía antes es
un best seller realmente sus libros son
un fenómeno desde hace más de una década
en francia
libros libros sí sí es interesante leer
los osos son libros en los que podrían
decir de historia divulgativa o de
pseudo historia en el que el espigón es
una una historia de francia como un país
en declive declive total francia se está
hundiendo y él denuncia y expone esto
con un poco historia una especie de
historia divulgativa o podríamos ir de
sobremesa no muy rigurosa pero que llega
muy bien ahora está mucho con una parte
de garau lazio y él acaba de sacar un
libro ahora acabar un libro y su campana
su precampaña electoral en realidad es
una gira de venta de libros el lunes
estuve en una de sus actos que consistía
el acto pues él sentado en una mesa
firmaba libros centenares y centenares
de libros decir de entrada lo que está
haciendo es vender muchos libros y no
hay que descartar aunque yo creo que es
poco probable hay que descartar que todo
esto al final quede en una gran
operación comercial en la que ha vendido
libros pero esto un hombre como él no
pone en marcha todo el aro y no ve estos
sondeos y no contra él tiene un equipo
ya de asesores políticos si no piensa y
creo yo en algo máster es pues es
probable y es posible es muy posible que
próximamente en próximos días semanas
declarar su candidatura por lo tanto que
quiere vender libros y quiere también
entrar de lleno en el debate político
francés y seguro yo creo que ahora él
cuando por la mañana se afeita delante
del espejo ya se imagina
presidente cuando uno pasa de no tener
nada en dos meses tener el 15 como dice
algún santo en los 16 por ciento de
votos está clasificado para la segunda
vuelta sin partido sin equipo
prácticamente viviendo de la nada y
llegar a eso yo creo que luego de este
señor debe estar muy subido en estos
momentos
jugando con una ambigüedad que todavía
le refuerza más jugar con no anunciar
pero estará ahí en la pomada es decir
este señor debe estar con un nuevo
volviendo a tu pregunta la víctima
principal de este fenómeno es marín
lópez claro porque vemos hay que matizar
mucho los sondeos que le dan 13 un 15%
pero
sí sí sí los vemos así imaginen es
cuando sube el baja
hay una conexión muy clara entre las dos
dinámicas electorales
también porque jugando en esa idea del
declive de francia de que francia ya no
es francia y jugado con una distancia
enorme de que hemos perdido el país de
nuestros padres y todo esto claro esto
lo atribuyen el a la inmigración que
cambió la
demográficamente el país
se queda un poco como la moderada porque
como líder del gasto nacional como ya
candidata a la presidencia le replican
dos veces ella estaba en busca de sin
dejar a un lado el discurso sobre el
islam y la inmigración y lo persigue con
él los temas de la ultraderecha pero
estaba en busca de una presentarse como
una figura
más responsable que que pueda gobernar
y que la gente no piense que de una
ultraderechista en el vicio es una idea
completamente loca no entonces llega a
él y dice no se está volviendo
mainstream
ya tiene un poco del discurso claro de y
aunque la principal perdón considero que
es la más afectada también manila pero
los movimientos todos los cambios de
derechas vemos que están haciendo
movimientos que ha irrumpido en la
campaña de una forma brutalmente e
incluso está también resquebrajando a la
misma derecha que de por sí no está
unida ahora con esos candidatos que
también michel barnier están también
otras figuras como eric ciotti que
también es un diputado de los alpes
marítimos y él dijo bueno ya si él se
presenta en segunda vuelta yo voy más
por el que
está
dentro del derecho a cada uno te tiene
que posicionar sobre ese acto si el
racista no es racista ya hay algunos que
lo piensan pero no lo quieren decir
porque temen que él electoralmente
entonces si vamos hablar de la derecha y
de la izquierda porque claro esto es un
hándicap tremendo para la derecha que se
tiene que posicionar con entre un macro
que le ha robado muchísimos votos y
muchísimo espacio y todo este fenómeno
de las ultraderechas en el en el otro
lado y con unas primarias una especie de
primarias que van a decidirse el 4 de
diciembre en las que el principal
candidato en los sondeos dentro de que
los antes de cogerlo con pinzas xavier
bertrand va por libre es decir la
situación en la familia conservadora es
bastante compleja
es muy mala es muy mala no tiene ningún
candidato destacado no saben cómo elegir
el candidato y les ha parecido como
recordaba el fémur que una
particularidad de fémur es que él no
viene de sus ideas son de extrema
derecha claramente pero él no viene de
la extrema derecha él era un peso era un
periodista o en seguida él publicaba
hasta hace un par de semanas semanas en
le figaro gran diario conservador pero
moderado de de francia el muchos
votantes de la derecha tradicional que
nunca se les habría ocurrido votar a
marine lepén porque la asocian a la
frente nacional a un partido ultra no
republicano como dicen aquí no aceptable
para el gobierno en cambio es paradójico
en cambio votarían azemur aunque se
muere es más extremista que es que marie
le pen el fémur sí sí sí la operación
azemur funciona que yo yo soy yo soy
cauto no sé todavía el que pasará anís y
dentro de 15 días será una burbuja que
habrá pinchado pero si esta operación
funciona de moore puede dinamitar al
frente nacional jean-marie le pen y
también
una parte la más derechista de la
derecha tradicional de los republicanos
se podía concebir y la más moderada
sí exactamente es que finalmente es la
hora que el punto de quiebre para los
que están todavía indecisos y que
también ahí a ver se llama cron el juega
lo mismo de irse con el extremo no el
corto también apuesta porque le conviene
pero yo creo que es creer en mucho
cuidado de no subestimar justamente este
apoyo que está la derecha tiene
problemas hasta a la hora del formato
para elegir el candidato que finalmente
va a ser el 4 diciembre que se alargue
esto en el tiempo y que se dilate este
proceso al final no deja demasiado
espacio precisamente hace moore en toda
esta historia claro y sobre todo porque
ese muro tiene una libertad que no
tienen los otros porque no es miembro de
ningún partido no tiene qué
es respetar la lealtad hacia ninguna
figura persona y esa libertad de
discurso también yo creo que explica por
parte el léxico del éxito que tiene algo
que comercial marque lo mejor la burbuja
se pincha pero vamos a aguantar mucho
con la burbuja porque ahora no interesa
posicionarse como candidato vamos a
seguir con la burbuja de vida también
porque si es candidato de verdad quién
lo va a apoyar porque en la campaña
electoral sobre todo la presidencia en
las repúblicas mucho es mucho dinero
no necesita 500 firmas de cargos electos
para presentarse entonces ya veremos
cuando tenga que la dura
hablar con la derecha de manera claro o
el frente la ciudad bueno vamos a
analizar más puntos hablando del
centroderecha de centroizquierda a ver
ven más fácil un candidato potente que
salga de la especie de primaria de la
derecha al 4 de diciembre o ven más
posible que la izquierda se reúna en
torno a hidalgo o hallado es una
pregunta muy bonita en la cual apuestan
antes
quizá haber de bayas que les queda
también aquí tiene siempre está está
clara
característica de que jamás se unen o ya
lo vemos ya dota acaba decir hace unos
días también de nor no ahora sino nos
desplegamos con el partido socialista
vamos en firme y vamos por el gobierno
será que le da está todavía la duda no
creo como marc
yo creo que tiene algo que hacer en
estas presidenciales porque a lo mejor
tendremos que empezar por ahí si no se
une no tiene cero opciones y damos por
sentado que nos va a unir ya veremos
ahora no todos dicen que no por lo menos
hay 33 candidatos de cierto peso que es
la socialista anne hidalgo el ecologista
y anillado y el populista ya un link
melón son si cada uno va por libre
es imposible que ninguno de los tres
llegue a las la segunda vuelta si van
unidos por lo menos dos de ellos podrían
unirse han hidalgo y iniciado que son
podríamos decir la izquierda más
moderada social y ecológica
quizá podrían acercarse a la prueba
posibilidad de pasar a segunda vuelta
pero ni siquiera si sería seguro los
números y quizá volvemos a la pregunta
que nos hacías antes sobre si francia ha
ido a la derecha los números no suman
pero aún suman menos si van divididos
ahí sí que no hay no hay ni cualquier
caso la única posible sería la del
socialismo y el ecologismo nos damos por
descontado que la izquierda radical
no va a unirse y menos una figura como
ya no porque bueno primero
históricamente siempre siempre ha habido
dos candidaturas de izquierda en francia
y en muchos países el bueno antes era
los socialistas y los comunistas y esos
dos espacios de la izquierda siguen
existiendo ahora bien los granas están
muy muy débiles como partidos estamos en
una etapa en la que cada uno intenta
[__] el liderazgo sobre la izquierda
porque si miramos lo que pasó por
ejemplo en la última elección
presidencial en el 2017 ya había dos
candidaturas de la izquierda y a partir
del mes de marzo abril las curvas se
empezaron a cruzar y claro lo que pasa
es que el electorado de izquierda al
final va a votar al candidato a la
cañada que más opciones tienen para
llegar a la segunda vuelta el drama de
la izquierda para mí no es la división
en sí que claro si se alían los
ecologistas y los socialistas y tienen
matemáticamente más
más opciones pero el drama es que toda
la izquierda incluido la ultra izquierda
pesa menos del 30% del electorado ese es
el problema porque sabemos que el tique
para la segunda vuelta gracias al demo
está bajando pero el problema es lo que
decíamos de la vaga la batalla cultural
y digamos eso es el peligro es un
peligro mayor que la división para antes
mar nombrar a esos temas que pueden
influir en campaña identidad economía
ecología dando por sentado que los datos
económicos son buenos para macro
izquierda va a intentar tirar de la
batalla ecológica aunque está muy
debilitada entendemos que el primer tema
el de la identidad es el que va a marcar
las opciones de la derecha y la extrema
derecha y que ese tema va a ser el tema
crucial según está en los sondeos es el
tema por lo se está marcando ahora en
estos momentos pero creo que rafael
apuntaba antes que atención con el poder
adquisitivo con unos nuevos chalecos
amarillos en este país hay erupciones
inesperadas este verano pareció que
podría haber una erupción de antivacunas
luego quedó como quedó desdibujado pero
hay atención a eso pero si ahora y por
eso está hace moore por eso el fenómeno
del frío y por eso por ejemplo tiene
tanto éxito esta película que no sé si
habéis visto de bach no sé qué es una
película que retrata la vida cotidiana
de la policía en los barrios difíciles
de marsella y que muestra pues zonas de
la república francesa donde el estado no
no gobierna y gobierna las bandas es
decir hay un factor cultural y hay un
malestar en una parte de francia que
tiene que ver con la identidad con la
inmigración y en el que se murga
enormemente pues muchísimas gracias me
quedo ya sin tiempo ha sido un placer
muy interesante analizar con ustedes
toda la actualidad política francesa ya
ven cómo están las elecciones de cara a
2022 va a ser muy muy muy interesante y
a todos ustedes les esperamos a quien en
primera plana la próxima semana muchas
gracias
[Música]